hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to 2016. so 2015 last year was
already like in terms of video easily
the crispiest year of all time no doubt
december alone by itself was awesome we
had we passed 3 million subscribers
which was awesome we had a little cameo
in youtube rewind 2015 which was a lot
of fun we had the kobe interview we had
the smartphone awards and we're pretty
much looking to pick up right where we
left off so kicking off 2016 per usual
like every year is ces so the consumer
electronics show every january in las
vegas i'll be there and of course many
others will be and we'll have a lot of
fun making video but ces itself is sort
of it's it's not a shrinking show but a
lot of the stuff that used to be like
really big announcements has sort of
outgrown ces so they move out and they
have their own announcement elsewhere so
what remains at ces is a lot of the more
interesting smaller stuff so i'm not
doing a video on every single thing i
see at ces there will be channels that
do that but i'm going to be just
focusing on the coolest stuff i see at
the show like i do every year so of
course let me know what you guys see if
you hit me up on twitter stuff you see
in the news about ces that you want to
see a video on that's the stuff i'm
going to be sharing and even if it
doesn't make it into a video i'll
probably tweet about it and share the
cool stuff i find now this is also your
annual reminder to turn on email
notifications for new uploads so your
subscription box might get a little bit
crazy sometimes but you can always count
on email reminders of new uploads to
remind you not only on a very reliable
basis but pretty much instantaneously
like when i hit publish the email goes
out from youtube like within seconds so
you can be among the first to watch so
that's definitely the way to go and
another little piece of news
this is one of the last videos that you
guys will see
in this apartment
so yeah i've lived here for the last
four years while i was going to school
up here i no longer go to school up here
so i'm sort of outgrowing this place so
i guess remember what you like about it
remember the scene uh i'm gonna miss
some parts of it like the heater making
noise while i'm trying to record i'll
miss that anyway i just wanted to make
this video to say happy new year welcome
to 2016 and uh hopefully i my sincere
goal is to make every video that i make
this year
better than every video that i made last
year it's like my new year's resolution
or is my new year's resolution 4k
or is it 8k
anyway i'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace